para qué 60 cruceros son investigados en
Estados Unidos por la aparición de casos
de covid-19 a bordo
a varios de ellos se les ha impedido
atracar en puertos del Caribe en un
buque de la compañía Royal Caribbean
International 55 personas dieron
positivo por coronavirus por lo que no
se le permitió detenerse en Curazao y
Aruba
tuvo que permanecer el martes de su
partido el 18 de diciembre está su
regreso este domingo a Fort Lauderdale
los contagiados eran parte de la
tripulación y los pasajeros aunque el
95% de los que estaban a bordo estaban
vacunados
otro crucero de la compañía Carnival
Freedom no fue autorizado atracar en la
isla irlandesa de Bonaire a pesar de que
son considerados lugares súper
propagadores del virus los turistas de
este crucero en Florida siguen adelante
con el viaje
tenemos a todos nuestros amigos con
nosotros y esperamos que todo dentro
esté abierto y mientras todos los coach
todos los bares todo está abierto creo
que nos lo vamos a pasar bien
genial estaba esperando de estudiante 2
años pero también me vacunaron así que
ahora voy a usar mi máscara aunque no es
obligatorio en algunos lugares solo para
estar segura
escobi 19 provocó la suspensión de las
actividades de cruceros durante más de
un año desde junio volvieron a operar
con exigencias como la obligatoriedad de
vacunas para empleados y adultos mayores